l'afrique pourrait faire face aux mêmes
problèmes que l'europe dont quelques
semaines à peine
elle a besoin de notre aide pour
ralentir la propagation du virus
comme nous avons eu besoin d' aide dans
cette crise c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'union européenne garantis
plus de 15 milliards d'euros pour aider
nos partenaires dans le monde à lutter
contre le coronavirus 15 milliards
d'euros pour répondre à l'urgence
humanitaire
une enveloppe destinée aux pays les plus
en difficulté qui pourrait profiter
notamment à la région du sahel sur place
nombreux sont les réfugiés qui s'alarme
de l'arrivée du coït 19 comme ici au
mali en périphérie de bamako on a peur
d'être contaminés à tel point que cela
ne nous empêche de dormir nuitées joie
je vis ici avec ma famille
et si l'un de nous attrape cette maladie
ça va être une catastrophe
il ya maliens ont malheureusement on est
ici parce qu'on n'a pas le choix on
reste assis on imagine le pire que l'un
d'entre nous soit infecté face à
l'urgence certaines associations
apportent des kits sanitaires dans les
camps de personnes déplacées ouvre notre
campagne de sensibilisation par rapport
au cours d'un virus et donc qui parle de
campagne de sensibilisation qui concerne
le court nageuse parle également des
kits ce qu'il faut utiliser donc c'est
pour ça que nous avons ramené cinq kits
sanitaires là sur le crâne laissez nous
d'abord assez nous parce que nous nous
irons là où on a plus de confiance au
burkina faso dont la ville de kaya ce
sont plus de 530 mille personnes qui
font face à l'inquiétude
les gestes barrières semblent être
adoptée progressivement par les
habitants des campagnes de
sensibilisation sont menées à travers de
nombreux camps l'aide humanitaire de
l'europe
très attendu sur place vise à prévenir
et limiter les conséquences de cette
catastrophe sanitaire qui s'annonce